[Applause]
so this is quite possibly the best scene
if not definitely one of the best scenes
from Batman vs Superman and it's really
cool to see this scene side by side with
the stunt team's take on the right side
because it shows you what really went
into making this scene and I'm not sure
if you caught it but there are actually
two parts on the stunt team side that
didn't make it to the final film now
this movie and this scene have already
been highly criticized for Batman's
brutality and his willingness to kill
many fans didn't like this because
that's not how Batman is supposed to be
especially after the Dark Knight Returns
where Batman states that he doesn't use
guns
kidding me no guns no killing where's
the fun in that and in this scene he
uses his fair share of weapons automatic
guns included granted he is fighting a
ton of villains in this scene it would
be pretty hard for him not to use any
weapons at all but was it too much some
of the stabbing the breaking of the arms
breaking of the necks throwing the
wooden box at the guy who gets his head
smushed on the wall after many fans
thought that it was too brutal and they
actually did leave a scene out that is
kind of shown in this side-by-side and
that scene is Batman picking up one of
the bad guys and using him as a shield
to stop the bullets from the attack of
another bad guy we kind of see this at
the end where Batman picks up one of the
guys kind of turns him to where bullets
are supposed to be hitting him and then
flings him at another bad guy this scene
was left out because apparently that's
where the line was drawn Batman doesn't
pick up people and use them as shields
to stop bullets granted Snyder said that
the character would be wearing a
bulletproof vest and wouldn't have died
but they still chose not to put the
scene in the final cut this scene
personally doesn't bug me I actually
thought it was probably the best scene
in the movie but I can certainly
understand how people didn't like it
thinking it wasn't really true to
Batman's character and Batman was
definitely toned down from Batman vs
Superman in Justice League what do you
all think of this scene do you think
that it was too much or did you like it
and do you think that the scenes that
were taken out should have been put in
or rightfully so left out let me know
what you think in the comments below and
just a reminder that I am doing an
Avengers infinity war blu-ray giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]